This video was made in collaboration with Telekom.
Once upon a time...
There was a brave Swedish man,
called PewDiePie...
PewDiePie was an enthusiastic sailor...
He loved the ocean,
like he loved his stupid dog -
EDGAR.
Alright.
Alright, let's get serious for a little bit.
Deutsche Telekom, Alzheimer's Research and UCL have gotten together,
to make a mobile game,
to fight dementia.
That's pretty cool!
If you are not familiar with dementia,
one of the first signs of it
is loss of navigational skills.
Dementia steals your memories
and the times you had with the people you love.
It's...just...awful.
And this game was made to conquer that.
So, the game is split up in different areas
and basically you're a sea explorer,
and you need to navigate
to recover the lost memories of your father.
And you follow the same journey, as he took.
Ok, so here is where the game get's interesting:
The data from people playing this game and navigating around,
will be analyzed by scientists
and the more they get - the better results they will get.
Right now, there are over 49 million people sufferng from dementia
An noone has ever survived it.
There is no cure and it's increasing.
There is going to be 135 million people by the year 2050.
This game's goal is to generate the largest, crowdsource, global benchmark,
for how people navigate.
So, if 100 000 people play this game for 2 minutes,
we can generate 58 years of lab research.
Bro's,
check out this game.
I am going to donate $50,000 to Alzheimer's Research, as well.
Please, check out this game in the description,
It' s a really cool thing and I think
if all you bro's checked out this game, download it on your phone -
we can all help to support research for dementia.
I think that's fucking awesome.
That is really cool, and I would love if you bro's
checked it out, tweet #gameforgood
with a screenshot of you playing the game.
I think, that would be awesome!
Now, let's get into some other games as well!
Sheep...
They're all sheep...
One person plays the game...
and the rest just follows...
Think for yourself!
Find your originality!
I am so fucking tired!
Look, they even used the same fucking thumbnail!
I'm so tired
of all these people
just copying each other!..
It is copying!
Anyway, welcome to "Life. The Game."!
My name is PewDiePie-the most original youtuber.
This is all...get born!
Okay.
That is fucking disguasting.
I am sorry.
Okay, well, I failed at step one!
Well...I tried.
*The most original youtuber!*
I couldn't even get bored...born!
There it is!
*Song: Fly by Nicki Minaj feat Rihanna*
Talk! Umm...
I'm learning to speak.
I still haven't seem to be able to master this art of...
SHUT UP!
Oh God it's so fast pace! Okay we learn how to study!
Study, study!
Drag and drop...
UHHH...  H 2 no, uhhh 12 plus...
Twenty..se-eight?
Fuck you!
Well, I failed my grades, I still did fine...
Alright, seveteen, 3, twenty...
Bam-bada-boom! Brrrah!
Oh God, zits!
I got it in my eye?!
Dude, that zit is fucking nas
I did it! Puberty! No, wait...
I never got a single zit!
All the ladies were like: "Hey, that PewDiePie guy... "
Oh God, we even got a braces...
I never got braces, I never got zits!
I am 26, I still get these!
WTF is wrong with life?
"After the "Pimple accident" you became the Nipple face guy..."
I am still the Nipple face guy!
Okay, I did it!
Now we go on a date. This has never happened in my life.
*Song: Naraku no Hana*
Uhhh...she looks boring.
"You nope'd one of the cutest girls...it's your biggest regret of your life...". Try again.
Oh, I gotta be real fast, okay!
Yes!
Uhh, no!
It's a match.
Okay, spo... WHAT?
Come on!
I am hitting so many balls, dude!
Oh, okay, I can just do that.
I did it!
*laughing*
Oh, make coffee!
Uhhh...
Did I miss?
I did it! Whoaa!
Get married, bitch!
I'll get married like this!
Listen, if Marzia don't want me like this...
She can have it!.. No, she can date Edgar!
Alright, fine, I'll add the panties.
Alright, fine, Jesus...
Yaaay, get kids!
*peew*
Come on, Marzia!
Uuh, this is kinda weird.
Midlife crisis!
"Shopping list: New car".
Those, please!
New car, weights!
We're gonna travel now.
Hey, I got ripped at list.
Grand children!
Drag and drop!
Uh, oh, oh God, she got sucked in!
What the fuck! No, don't!..
No, don't f...!
Timmy, you're fucking!..
What is with kids?!
Dilan & Pewds: I HATE PEWDIEPIE!
PewDiePie sucks!
Yay, stay healthy.
It's a bit to fucking short for that mate!
Getting old fucking sucks...
I hope when I die, at least I get it on camera.
So Edgar can upload that shit and cash in on it.
I did it, holy shit...
WHAT?!
NO!
Loved by all
That's hysterical
That's a very creative game.
I applaud. Very well done.
Moving on to the next game!
I know what you're thinking!
"Eeh, are this real or are they fake?"
Yeah, well guess what! Only Marzia and Edgar, maybe, will know the true answer!
Okay, "Real or fake".
Now, I've done...I consider myself a bit of a...
a "conwazzer" of real and fake.
I've done a lot of photoshop fakers and I think I've got
a special eye for when it's real.
I've seen a lot of fakes in my life and I now what's real or not.
I can tell if a photo is real or fake.
I'll tell you like it IS!
I am like the Kanye West of the Youtube,
except everyone hates m-me, everyo...
*sad piano music*
Anyway, let's play this one!
Alright, so, real or fake?
Now, I'm gonna go with real!
BOOM!
Bzing!
That is a fake, you can see the shadow...
Doesn't fucking make any sense, go fuck off!
That is so obiously fake, the fish looks as nothing!
Let me fix the image for you, alright...
You got to match the fucking contrast, like, what is this?
Oh God, this is so fucking terrible...
Let's blend it a little better dude
Yeah, that makes all the difference...
Gotta add a little bit of shadow, take away the pixels...
It's all in the details!
Now, this is the type of photo that's like...
...so incredible, that you're like:
"Well that can't be real"
Alright, I'm gonna go with this is fake.
Of course.
Why would a fucking picture of a owl be fake?
Is the owl fake?
Is the owl telling us lies?
Like what-the-fuck-is-this-fucking-shit?!
Why would this be fake?
It's, it's real, right?
Of course it's real!
THAT EAGLE IS SO OBVIOUSLY PHOTOSHOPED, WTF?!
WHY WOULD THERE BE A FAKE PICTURE OF A BABY?
What the fuck is this?
Why would be church be fake?
Well, before... WHAT?
BEFORE THEY HAD A COUPLE?
HOW THE FUCK WOULD I KNOW THEY HAD A COUPLE THERE BEFORE?!
HOW WOULD I KNOW THAT!
What the fuck is this stupid piece of shit?
I've never been this pissed off in my life!
Fuck you!
Hey bro's, thanks for watching the video! I forgot to do an outro.
I am in New-York right now, so this will be the outro.
Please remember to checkout "Sea Hero Quest"!
I really appreciate it bro's, it's for a good cause, it's in the description.
I will post my donation on Twitter, so you know it's coming.
And that's it! Thanks for leaving a like, bro's
and as always...
stay awesome!
*BROFIST*